all right
all rise i always wanted to be in court
when they said that all rise
and see if i could have an erection when
the judge said that
and just kind of laughed to myself um
what's up you little skittle lickers i
uh
i feel honored to be here with you today
and happy day to you and um
i am i got a lot to share and
i'm sure you do so we'll get into it i
just shaved
um
you know i can't i'll be honest with you
i can't shave with a shirt on
i can't do it
i see people you know and not in real
time i don't watch men shave
and i'm not saying if there's nothing
wrong if you do i don't
you know i've only ever seen men shave
on a commercial
but i realized about myself i can't
shave with a shirt on
i shaved shirtless
i shaved shirtless and i think uh my dad
shaved shirtless you know my dad
when i met my dad he was a senior
citizen and he's he was damn
and that's as much citizen as you can
get that's full citizen
and his body he had like a
senior body he had that old body you
know he had his
he had kind of
baby tits really baby he had white skin
because all the color i think had grown
out of his skin
and he had a couple moles i think could
have been nipples i don't know
he could have had moles or nipples
um
but i remember he would shave shirtless
and i would see him do it and
and i thought you know what
he's doing that the right way
let's go
here we go a little robert finley get it
while you can
take it bobby
[Music]
who's gonna break my back
wrap it up
come on bobby
[Music]
if
wrap it up
and get it when you can
and you got to take it where you can get
it you got to get it when you can
and he don't cut corners verbally
that's bobby finley right there
and uh damn i can't get my damn
got too much home i got a hat
hold on sorry i got a hat and i got a
hat in
my specs
and my shades got a lot on got a lot on
here today and uh
i don't need those volume enhancers the
earphones right now
um good to be here with you today
and yeah you got to take it while you
can get it
you know and that's life life is a
serving each day
you get a serving of life
then you can you can accept it you can
try and digest it properly
you can reject it sometimes
you know sometimes i'll stop i'll starve
i'll life will be right in front of me
but i will starve i will say
you know i'm gonna be alive but i'm not
really gonna
not really gonna accept this day
i'm not really gonna take this bad boy
on i'm not really gonna
have this as a meal today
and i'll do that a lot i'll say no
i ain't eating i ain't eating today life
i don't want any i don't need any i'm
off the clock today
um what's going on i had a nice i know
i'm late on this weekend i tried to do
the episode yesterday i wasn't feeling
good
and uh and i couldn't do it i couldn't
do
i couldn't do it so i didn't do it
i probably should have just went ahead
and did it
but i wanted to try and be in a little
bit better head space
um oh i saw dustin the diamond poirier
this past weekend he was in
uh out here in the central east he was
doing a meet and greet
and meeting people that love fighting
and love watching people fight on
television and on
uh illegally streamed
fight source pat you know wherever they
watch fights
so that was good man we had a nice time
went out with him and his wife
and uh you know it was funny man we went
to a bar afterwards and
you know there was just a couple people
in there and they didn't know who dustin
was they didn't know about fighting
and so they're talking to him about i
don't know tennis or something i just
and it just man you can't be
you can't have the diamond right there
the champion baby you know
that french champ you can't have him
right there
and be talking about tennis
be talking about monopoly you can't be
sitting in heaven
and talking about hearties
and that's what these people were doing
and it just made me laugh but
man we had a great time man we had so
much fun his wife is so
funny uh
we just had a good time man and you know
we talked about life and a little bit
about
you know just what was going on in our
lives and it was good to catch up and
and it was nice to be amongst friends um
oh i'll tell you this um
you know i i've told this story before
that
there was a man when i was growing up
there was a man named don big don
blankenstein and he was a pool man
and he'd come over and do the pool you
know treat the pool and clean the pool
and
hell he used to even he'd get a little
scoop and taste it
make sure the kids were you know pissing
well i guess i have no idea but
um you know when i when i used to work
on this farm in the summer
big don would roll over there and he was
a big fella
you know he probably about 300 pounds
and this is back when
this is back when three 400 pounds would
kill you now people could go six seven
hundred pounds
and it's not really killing them out of
the gate
but back then it was three you go three
four hundred
[Music]
you know that would kind of kill you but
now with modern medicine people can go
up to 600
and they're alive for at least a couple
months or years like that
you know they're not going to see many
wrestlemanias but they'll see a couple
but uh but big don came one one summer i
was back there working on this farm and
the people i worked for had a pool and
and this man comes in the gate and he's
real thin real lean fella
you know just look like a
just look like a just a regular fella
like a librarian
man so you know what i'm talking about
kind of a little bit of glasses maybe
you know had hands like workers hands
though like you've been
like you've been turning the pages of
books but heavy books you know real
heavy paper
i'm talking 300 pound test paper
and uh and i said who is this man you
know i didn't know who this
man was looking at the pool i'd know
only seen big don
and so my thought was that you know big
don had passed on that weight he'd
his his life had caved in under that
weight and that weighted one you know
um but but but the truth was that big
don had lost the weight he got this
stomach surgery where they staple your
stomach directly to the ass you know so
whatever you eat comes
i mean it's i mean damn some things you
eat them they come out cleaner out the
back you know your body will just wash
it out whatever it is
you have four carrots and [ __ ] is
cleaned out
you know you eat a dirty squash and damn
next thing you know
you clean squashing you know right out
there in your underpants you got faux
freshly
cleaned squashes in your unders
and that was big don had that capability
i felt like you know that
maybe he got that surgery and i didn't
know that big donna got the surgery but
he got it
and so this man's wandering around the
pool and
and i didn't realize it was him he's
talking to me like we're friends you
know because me and don are friends
and suddenly i'm like holy damn that's
don
damn that's dawn and
uh and it was man he got the surgery
and he was he was just a new man you
know he was just different he was
he was different but anyway i tell you
that story because the other night
i'm out with the diamond and i'm out
with his wife and we're out and about
and
there was a guy who had had the surgery
he had the uh you know the d
fatten or whatever it's called i don't
know what it's called where they d where
they just
you know you show up as meal and
freaking leave out as veal you know they
freaking
they clean you down they wash it or wash
me down
they clean you down baby and um and big
don
it had it and so anyway there's this guy
at the bar and he had had it i guess but
he had this
he like kind of moved his arm he was
still moved like he was
four or 500 pounds but he was about 210
pounds now
and he still he would kind of put his
hands out on his stomach like he had
ghost belly
you know i'm talking about where
somebody just like he had just
he would he was still kind of like down
by the river
you know but he was a lean man it just
so it was just funny how you can have
things from the past that will still
take shape in your life you know
that was interesting to me just how you
could have things from the past that
will still
like still rule the way
you behave even if they're gone
i mean so much so this man was walking
through the crowd and saying excuse me
excuse me sorry
anybody i know where i can get a you
know
a triple xl shirt just saying old [ __ ]
just having flashbacks of fat
and of that weight and of that extra
and it was just interesting to watch it
was like it's funny even though we
change
sometimes some of the things we just
still hold on to you know and
um
[Music]
and god bless big don and god bless
anybody that's on that journey
you know that's trying to get rid of
something whether it be something
apar some of their body or some of their
brain or some of their
just something trying to let go of a
memory or of a
of a of a piece of an appendix
you know we all got some kind of
appendixes sometimes and
sometimes they're in our body sometimes
they're in our brains sometimes they're
you know they come in all types
they come in all types man um both of
those stories like about
you know how we take on life and how we
accept it each day
and if i choose to live it and and now
how i have things in my life that
you know like uh how i carry extra
baggage extra weight
whether it's in my body or in my brain
we all have
some type of gristle that's running on
us
and um and it can
gum up the works you know and i've seen
i mean i've seen the happiest people
in the world you know have big body
types and then i've seen the
the unhappiest people in the world have
lean body you'll see a skeleton and that
thing will be damn miserable
you know um
and i've always wished they had real
real real mannequins
every mannequin you see looks like you
can't find a shirt that fits anybody
because a mannequin he you know
they just they don't where i want i want
to see that mannequin with that hunch
back you know
who was in a mowing accident you know
who was doing a push mower and got hit
by a damn meteorite
you know on a downhill and so they're
not doing well you know
they got that 710 split around that l5
s1 you know they got that damn
they got that s curve on the spine you
know they're not doing
super great i want to see that mannequin
or that beer belly mannequin where is
that guy
you know or where's that mannequin with
that shoulder mold
you know what i'm saying and he got that
damn
you know that baby button sometimes if
you have somebody shirtless in your
family around a baby
and that person have a big mole on them
the baby will hit it
you know that was easy you know what i'm
saying the baby will just
that's that baby button maybe a decent
mole so
but anyway i want to tell you about an
experience that i had man um
a new type of therapy that i just went
and tried uh but first i'm gonna tell
you that uh
that two out of three men and this could
be adult men or young
even child men will experience some form
of hair loss by the time they are 35
jesus jesus
i mean god that's a bait and switch
isn't it they give you hair and they
take it away
baby they take it away
you'll see somebody 36 years old just
cornrowing some of their skin or just
i saw i saw a brother the other other
day he'd drawn some cornrows on his head
bald headed guy
you'll know or sometimes you'll see a
brother he'll have just a
he didn't even get real hair put in his
hair he got some damn yarn
i saw a guy the other day had two he
looked like a
just like a dark raggedy andy you know
that choco raggedy andy he just
like damn you got damn arts and crafts
in your head bubby
but what i'm telling you is more than 50
million
men in the us suffer from male pattern
baldness man
damn damn
there are only two fda approved
medications
that can prevent hair loss and keeps
offers both that's right
keeps offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair
they have a convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications
delivered straight to your door every
three months you don't have to leave
your home
some people you go out looking for hair
it used to be you go to the uh toupee
shop
or the two uh yeah toupee
two-page shop they got that french hair
they peddling over there
like damn man come on give me some [ __ ]
that's made in america baby you know
what i'm saying give me that fade out of
ohio baby
give me that freaking that youngstown
freaking mohawk
but they have discreet packaging and
proven results keeps has more
five star reviews than any of its
competitors prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act
fast that's right act fast
it's you got to be proactive with your
hair if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss
go to keeps p k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash theo to get uh to receive
your first month of treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
t-h-e-o to get your first month free
keeps.com slash theo
get the first month free i'm taking
keeps right now and i'm excited about it
you guys know i'm gonna you know i gotta
keep this
i got that i got that trying carpet man
on my head and i'm aladdin baby i gotta
keep it
i gotta keep this thing i gotta keep uh
you know it's funny you could be a
farmer but you can you manage that nine
square inches on your head that baby
acre
you could take the best farmer in the
world you could take
johnny appleseed or even his daddy mr
ron appleseed or whatever his name was i
don't know
let me see it johnny appleseed
parents
elizabeth simons and nathaniel chapman
you could take nathaniel
chapman who was johnny apple seed daddy
and even liz simon simons
and uh
and you wonder even though they could do
all that plant and all that forestation
could they keep their hair
could they keep their hair and it makes
you feel something as a man if you can't
keep your hair a little
like damn
it's just like father time just playing
hide and go seek with you
and first he hides a little bit of your
hair and then he hides a little bit of
your dick magic
and then he hides a little bit of uh
maybe a e-jack you can't eat jack as
decently or whatever
or spill heavy
maybe high then he hides something else
he hides you some of your dexterity
you can't write a sentence real fast on
the tip rider
you know where you can um
you can't do a rubik's cube
you know just different [ __ ] like that
he hides it
and then father time he hides this and
he hides that
and then you just left looking
looking at the clock baby
that hit man baby time that hit man
um i'm going to tell you also though
that uh
mint mobile after years of
fine print contracts and getting ripped
off
by big wireless providers and they do it
oh sometimes in my dreams i'll see big
wireless in the distance
smoking a doral you know and huffing gas
huffing damn uh keyboard cleaner
[ __ ] them you know i'll see them hating
on me from afar
and a near that's big wireless they
don't give a damn
they'll be listening to you talking
stealing your money that's how they are
they dirty nasty brother
they dirty nasty so when i heard that
mint mobile offers premium wireless
service starting at just 15
bucks a month i thought what's the catch
but after speaking with them and using
their service it all made sense
there isn't one mint mobile's secret
sauce
is that they are the first company to
sell wireless service online
only by cutting out retail stores
there's no crazy overhead costs
that get passed down to you in the form
of mystery fees
nope that's right they just passed the
savings directly on to you
for people looking for extra savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless
for just 15 bucks a month because it's
through the wi-fi that's how they do it
that's right all plans come with
unlimited talk and text high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month
to get the plan shipped to your door for
free
go to mintmobile.com theo that's
mint mobile mint mobile.com
theo cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month mintmobile.com
theo there you go there you go
um so i want to tell you guys
you know i i uh i've been feeling good
for a long time and
you know i know i kind of share that on
here sometimes and
sometimes i don't want to share it
because i don't want to be like a debbie
downer i don't want to
have self-pity you know
it's kind of like if a man only has one
leg he don't say it all the time
you know and sometimes he'll have a good
attitude he'll joke about it he'll have
a little sign on his good leg say
my other leg is a ghost you know or
something
you know you'll see somebody you'll you
know sometimes you bring a sense of
humor
to a knife fight you know oh
and that's okay that's all ways that we
do things it's ways that i do things
anyway
um but yeah man i just the past year and
a half i just have not been feeling
really good
and i've been trying to battle it you
know i go to my
uh recovery meetings that's been trying
the past couple months you know it's
been tough it's been tough throughout
korva to stay heavy on the meetings
and to go and you know and just to find
to get commitment and to get people to
meet up in real time
and uh so anyway man uh
recently i decided to try ketamine
therapy
and you know
i was a little scared about it i'm still
a little bit scared
i've gone to two services of it
and uh and some people are thinking look
it's not some guy in like a in a you
know in the back of a u-haul doing it
where
you know you don't bring glow sticks to
it and [ __ ] like that even though that
would be
that would be great if i showed up with
glow sticks
in some little dust muppet side piece
you know
some little girl named biscuit door you
know
and she's out there wearing baby jewelry
and just smelling like dirt
talking about electric disco or whatever
that'd be so great if the next time i go
where uh i get a tongue piercing with
one of those uh
with like one of those glow stick tongue
rings in it
um but that's not it man it's like
it's a therapy you go and they infuse
ketamine into you there's a therapist in
the room
and you do therapy
the first time you go you just do
therapy and then
the subsequent times it's six sessions
you go
and you they infuse you with ketamine
throughout um
antra venus and then
you just talk and you talk about what's
going on
and and it's supposed to take away your
ego so you can discuss
things that are bothering you behind
your
day-to-day brain and
um and yeah
you know so anyway so that's where i'm
at man i'm trying it right now and
i'm really excited i'm hopeful about it
um
you know it's kind of exhilarating it's
kind of scary
uh the place is real professional and
they make you feel real comfortable that
i've been going
and what else i'm i'm still meeting with
my regular therapist i'm still going to
my recovery meetings
uh
[Music]
what else um
you know i didn't have a lot of sober
time on the table to
so you know some people will say oh well
that's
you're not sober anymore this that's
fine i'm not
at this point i'm worried about just
trying to feel
uh just trying new ways to get better uh
and to feel better and
um yeah and so i'm just hopeful man it
was really kind of scary like the first
session man we did
and man i just started
literally just bawling crying you know
just tears running out of my face like i
mean
just like they were trying to get into
america from another country i mean just
groups of them they had big tears
sneaking little tears i mean there was a
lot going on
you know and
we started talking i i we started
talking about my dad man i hadn't really
thought about my dad that much and
um you know i don't have a ton of
memories of my dad really i was just
getting old enough to be a human when he
was
losing his humanity you know as he got
older
on his way out you know and so we were
just like
you know like dogs passing in the park
you know
you know a quick sniff of the ass but we
kept
you know but we just had
you know
you know the way we never threw the
frisbee you know we never
you know we know you know it was just
that's kind of what it was and i'm not
saying it like a debbie downer i'm just
kind of sharing
um one of the things that we talked
about in the therapy was just about
uh like i'd never gotten to tell my dad
how much i loved him you know i never i
had all this love from my father that i
never got to put it anywhere
and so we talked about that in the
therapy um
and what else just talking about some
other things that have really been
bugging me man i've just felt really
agitated
easily i've felt a lot angrier than
usual
man and i'm just
interacting with people that i care
about sometimes in an angry way and it
makes me not feel good
you know it's like being in a
it's almost like being in a mask you
know i've talked about it before about
halloween when you're in like a scare
mask you know when you're in a uh
when you wolfin or whatever and you
wolfed out with a
headpiece with a mask on
and you got that bad cat [ __ ] uh
you got that bad cat death sock on your
head baby that you know that
costume that mask and
and sometimes when you're looking out of
the mask you can see out of the mask you
see
normally it's your eyes looking but the
people that see you if a child sees you
he gets scared
you know he'll drop his damn baby ruth
bro and go hug his step daddy or
whoever's with him
you know and so um
anyway so that's what it's like
sometimes that's what it felt like me
for me sometimes in the past years just
kind of anger
and i don't know what i'm angry about
and i'm tired of not knowing
um and so i'm just trying to get i'm
trying to figure it out
and uh and so anyway that's what's going
on man
and and i just noticed that i was
like uh other people i noticed were i
just i'm not interacting with people the
same the way that i want to be
in like a loving way um
and i'm desperate for that you know
that's the part of life that i like to
devour every day
really you know when i felt like i was
doing well with it for a while and then
it's been tougher
as of late
and i know there's a lot of stuff in the
world that's making people angry and
making people feel dilapidated in their
spirit
you know there's a lot of like america
that's been
you know a lot of the fabric of our
society
i feel like is being unwoven
by the media and by
i don't know just people just want to
dismantle a lot of tradition and a lot
of like things that make you feel like
you're
part of a society
you know everything is constantly
challenged and
in society it was always what i felt
like i was in you know i felt like i was
in this
you know this calendar this world you
know there's just certain little
systems of the day and of the week and
of life that go on that make you
feel like you're part of something
and i think during the disease uh
i think during the disease a lot of that
stuff has gone is
kind of you know well
a lot of it's been impossible to to
spend time over
and as well a lot of media has just
attacked everything
you know every every place you turn
they're attacking some piece of
something that mints that that even if
it was a
business or a or anything that it meant
something to you it felt like
um and that's okay because i know
different things mean different things
to different people but
uh i think some of that anyways probably
led to some of my angst and some of my
own comfort
and i'm sure a lot of people can relate
to that and how to not be angry and
and express my anger where to express it
and how to express it as a
as an adult because i'm an adult
so anyway i didn't mean to get all heavy
with that kind of stuff but
i'm just willing to try i'm healthy i'm
willing to try
things that are unique experiences um
and so that's what i'm trying right now
with this ketamine therapy and ketamine
solution so one of my buddies i told him
he's like so damn dude you just been
doing drugs all day
and i said no man no man uh
you know it's kind of exhausting a
little bit emotionally exhausting
um
but i'm hopeful about it man i'm hopeful
uh
that it i don't know i'm just willing to
try it
i'm willing to try different things baby
you know i'm like that lewis and clark
i'm that emo nemo baby i'll [ __ ] i'll
swim out in the deep dawg
to get a worm baby boy
so that's where i'm at i just wanted to
let you guys know what was going on
but i just haven't enjoyed some of the
ways of my own behavior
and sometimes i feel like i'm inside of
myself looking out of the holes of
of a shape that i don't even recognize
sometimes
and i'm not being extra hard on myself i
know i am
that's one of the things that we're also
going to try and talk about in this
therapy is why i'm so hard on myself
and you know uh
and just expectations judge i mean just
all these things i'm just
you know i feel like sometimes i'm
like i'm like i'm a wi-fi and i have
these open browsers spinning
and i can't even see them anymore
you know and they're just different
weird browsers that have been open for
decades in my head
and one of them could be somebody
selling a uh a peanut butter or a banana
you know or somebody one of them could
be a damn uh
advertisement for draftkings you know
i'm saying you just don't even know one
of them could be that cat playing the
thing
but you don't know they're open because
you're trying to focus on a different
page and do
do life so
i don't know i'm just out there man i'm
out there that's where i'm at uh
but i just wanted to let you guys know
what was going on and
and try and share a little bit about how
i'm feeling and
uh
and yeah that's it man that's it
you know i don't feel i just feel
hopeful
i don't feel like i'm i just feel
hopeful man
so oh anyway
that's what's going on bro and lady
and everybody we got some great calls
that came in oh i realized the other day
one of my pet peeves
is if somebody has a toilet seat that
won't go
straight it won't stay up you ever get
that
so you in there you toileting
you know you in there you captain toilet
bro when i get in the bathroom i'm
captain toilet dawg
i'm captain toilet when i get in there
that's me and this is my vessel
and so if right out the gate the thing
you know that gate that piss gate keeps
coming down
and it's weird it's like your urine is
trying to get into guantanamo bay or
something it just
you know i start streaming and that
thing slowly start coming down
but who who is selling toilets where the
seat doesn't stay up and who's buying
them
you got a test drive
you got to test drive that booty vessel
baby you got to test
drive
that big uh that big urine gullet baby
because that thing will
i mean a good toilet will do everything
but suck you off and you know that
praise god and i'm sorry for talking
like that today
um all right what else we got we got
some great calls that came in
you know i got a new tour that's going
to be starting up in september the
tickets will go on sale
next week uh very hopeful about that
and what else um
that's about it really so i want to
uh i want to let you know that you guys
had some calls that came into the
hotline
and as always the hotline is
985-664-9503
where you can uh check in and be
involved and be a part of the show
i left the ac in in in on
on here today so if you hear something
it could be the ac
uh but yeah i'm hoping that this therapy
or something
in conjunction with other therapy that
i'm continuing to go to
um you know part of the ketamine's
therapy is that you also go to your own
therapist between
sessions so um
yeah so i'm hoping that it helps me
i don't know just want to have a
stronger communication with life
on a day-to-day basis
you know uh and i know a lot of that is
has to do with having a higher power and
an internal battle and
and um and i'm fighting on those fronts
but
uh yeah but that's it man i'm
you know i'm nervous but i'm also
excited so that's kind of where i'm at
we had some calls you guys had
suggestions for tour names that came in
and i've been trying to think it's hard
because dark arts tour man i felt like
we really did it well
and if you came out to that you really
had you know you had a nice time
so um so anyway let's hear some options
that came
in here we go yo theo this
woody g down here in palm beach florida
woody g and that's after a name after if
your penis hits that high note or that
or even a flat you know if you got that
penis that shows up on that octave scale
baby that's a
woody g let's hear more out here
cleaning pools
cement ponds little kid piss patches
oh yeah and dude the weirdest thing i
always thought honestly
was the kid that got out of the pool to
go inside and pee
why that was always the weirdest kid to
me that fella
that's like hey i'm gonna get out i'm
gonna dry off
then i'm gonna go inside and pee
dude pee in the pool man
have another freaking hot frank bruh and
pee in the pool huh
jeepers huh onward woody i'm sorry for
interrupting you brother praise god baby
anyway you asked for suggestions on the
new name of your new special
i think let's be honest would be a great
name
because let's be honest you the realest
best comedian out there
and that'll be the best name for your
new special bro we love you man
take care gang woody thanks man that's
sweet of you to say that man i love you
too
bro you know that's nice you to think of
me and say something nice to me
um you know that's just nice it's nice
that you were called to say something
nice
because usually people sometimes they
call you this you they they'll say
something crazy
yell the n-word or something they hang
up so it's nice to hear something
positive bro
let's be honest that might be a good
tour name or a good name for a special
we're going to be shooting a special for
netflix over in uh dallas it looks like
in
august but i don't know the dates yet
uh i will let you guys know first
when that goes on sale and uh and
patreoners will
you guys will get a first option too for
uh for some tickets too
so um just letting everybody know those
things
but thank you for that let's be honest
let's hear another one that came in this
kyle from nepal
what up theo this is uh kyle in napa
california
you might know me as a that guy that's
too handsome to teach brah
uh i sent a video to king steamwhile
back oh yeah now you can't be too
handsome and be working at a school
brother i don't think
it's just risky and you know what i'm
talking about some of you
it's just too risky if you you can't be
fine as hell and rolling up into a high
school
i don't care if you're 50 or 5 or 5.
i just think you're just
you're clocking in with the devil that's
what i feel like
you're clocking in with the devil
it's like when you bring sugar cubes
into an old folks home some of them
[ __ ] can't have
the sweet some of them [ __ ] can't
have the sweet
so when you roll in there
like freaking big donny sucrose
no you i mean
some of these old ladies in old men
they'll let you hold a titty for a damn
you know
for two little you know for a damn half
a dime worth of uh
of glucose daddy that's just where
they're at so it's just
and that's when you know when you
clocking in for the devil
when you show up somewhere and you know
that what you're doing
you tempting you tempting
let's hear more baby um but i'm just
sitting at my desk listening to some uh
this past weekend above the show
and uh one of your recent episodes you
said if you had some uh some name ideas
for your upcoming tour to share them so
i
thought of three just kind of thinking
about it um one you bounce around a lot
obviously you're national now living
there so i thought of nobody title
tendencies
so instead of suicidal or homicidals
nomad because you're a traveler
nama title nama title tendencies
um i like it i think the word nama title
is a bit
uh that could be challenging for some
i'm gonna say that
challenging for some let's hear more
another one you talked about beating the
uh the syndrome
all right so if you have downs they call
it trisomy 21
so you can just be trisomy 20.9
okay because i just cleared that hurdle
baby
you know i just cleared the lord's
hurdle son and you know that is a
that's a risky jump that's a risky jump
man
he beat it didn't get quiet to 21. then
that last one i heard that song 38
special so i was like
why why say when the bullet hits the
bone when it could be when the mullet
hits the bone
sure whatever you come up it'll be great
if you ever come out here to the bay
area now
california i'll be front row of that
show can't wait to see you
wish y'all the best love the show later
thank you kyle thanks for the suggestion
sir
much obliged um i think
i'll tell you this i worked on a game
show one time
it was like a chinese game show or
something or japanese no offense if
anybody is chinese or japanese
actually nobody's offended how the how
in the
[ __ ] would i know when
i was 20 years old if you wanted me to
know
at 20 years old if you were chinese or
japanese you would have needed to write
chinese or japanese on you
or wear a neck brace or something to say
chinese or japanese
you know and i respect japanese people
bro and i respect chinese people
it's china's a little bit definitely
dicier
you know if you want to gamble but with
your
entrails and stuff like that go over to
china
people are always like we could wear
masks forever man they do it in china
if you've been to china it is most
everyone there is seems very sad
and they do not seem like individual
people
they seem like a group of migratory
workers
for some higher power
that may be samsung and i don't say that
in offense to any chinese people
but i do say that is exactly what i've
seen
so i'ma say that man and i've said that
so that's it what else man let's hear
one more that came in here we go
what's up theo is ryan from here in
louisville kentucky
i've tried making this video probably
about 18 times and i might try to make
it another 12 but i don't know
my insecure ass but i feel you man i do
that all the time if i'm trying to do a
nice smile
for a lady or something on instagrams or
if i'm sending a photo to somebody
even my own family sometimes i'll try to
make it look decent
you know when man i wouldn't be great to
feel comfortable enough just to put my
feet forward whatever they are
whatever my hoofs are just to set them
out in the sun
dirty and nasty and nail polish and
fail polish whatever is on them man
stains anything
veins anything damn this is these are my
steppers baby this is what i've been
walking with
sorry to get into that let's go more
brother thank you for calling and i
understand
i got a name for your upcoming tour let
me know what you think about it
this past quarantine
i don't think i i don't think i don't
think i don't think
uh i don't think a ton about it
i do not think a ton about it but i'm
grateful that you sent it this past
quarantine oh actually now it's growing
on me now that i said it
this past quarantine
you know i think it would be a good
episode or a good like
i think by the tour if it's a year later
will people still be wanting to think
about quarantine
you know that's what i wonder uh
and then what if some people are you
know masked you know
real massed up i met a guy this morning
okay i'm having breakfast somewhere at a
uh at a damn egg deal and
i went i thought this fellow was this
man i knew named ryan i went up to him
and said hey are you ryan
he literally had to take off three masks
it was like watching
someone uh
be indoors and then like you know you go
to a ticket window sometimes you're
trying to talk to them they can't hear
you so they come out of the ticket and
come out of the venue or whatever
it was like that i had a way for him to
get this mask and then that one had a
padlock he had to get the key from his
buddy
you know then he had to uh you know then
he had to push his [ __ ] finger hit a
fingerprint man
the third one to unlock and finally he's
like nah my name's shannon
all right all right guy all right
and i did actually as soon as i noticed
he had three masks i didn't even want to
know him anymore even if it was the guy
i knew
if it would have been ryan i would have
said you know what ryan
i think we're good i think we're good
um thank you for all the suggestions you
know and uh
and and i appreciate them and who knows
one of those could be it and if i if i
do i'll reach out and discuss it with
you before i just take your name
um we got a couple videos that came in
right here let's see
let's see what uh some of this was and
some decent uh material visual material
oh and this is a car jumping the daytona
beach bridge
let's go let's go
if you can't see and you can't see it
because this is verbally for some of you
they have basically
they have a bridge that closes
one of those closing bridges and
sometimes it's by like a river
you know i grew up for a while over
there on a chewfunctor river
down there i'm in st tammany parish
louisiana and
they said that it got its name because
the chef de indians
named it and they got their name
because one of them had taken a large
rock
and thrown it into some water river
multiple water
and that's the sound it made when it
went in
and i always thought man that how
fascinating is that
how much closer to the earth can you
be than to be the octave or the
the the audio remnant
of the sound of a rock going into water
i mean
damn you on mother nature's tit
baby you doing full milk
and so i always thought that was
fascinating that the rock had made
when they threw it in the water and said
that's what they named their tribe but
anyway they had one of these bridges
where rich people
it would either every half hour the
bridge would open for boats to go
through
on weekends and every hour on weekdays
so if you were driving you had to stop
and wait it was a couple minutes
and then there was rumor that rich
people could get through whenever they
wanted
so i always hated that [ __ ] but
god i always this person in the video
speeds through the little candy cane
thing that tells you to stop
you know the little red and white stick
or whatever the stop stick
this dude blasts right through it and
then the ramp is going up so it's
already the road is separated the ramps
are going up on both sides the bridges
and this guy jumps the first one and
lands on the second one
i mean it's not a far jump but
i'll be damn if it isn't damn amazing
and he makes it
i mean it's just starting to separate
he just right through bam he made air he
had about
almost a full second of hair so
amen to that guy and maybe that's where
we're heading where people start to do
things themselves more
you know what i'm late for work oh well
you know that's one thing i worry about
the the the fabric of our
society being eroded sometimes and
and i'm not saying i'm right with some
of my speculations i'm just
i don't know over this whole thing it
started to feel like it doesn't matter
what month it is it doesn't matter what
the holidays are it's all
i don't know some of that's just felt
kind of defeating and
and i know there's ways to battle
against that i'm not saying that i'm
defeated
or that we should feel defeated but some
of those feelings have been adding i
think to
just to me not feeling good but um
anyway uh
[Music]
but maybe that's what really people just
creating new pathways baby
creating new pathways saying look this
is how we do it now if you want to make
the jump
if you want to be that bad boy that
daytona beach bridge
buster then get out there because this
dude
it's a wild it's a wild trip and one
thing that's interesting too about the
ketamine therapy they say it builds new
pathways in your brain
uh to help battle depression so
sometimes with depression you have a lot
of old thought processes
you know your thoughts will travel the
same roads
they get scared to go on new roads you
get stuck on these old roads and they
got potholes and they got
you know people probably [ __ ] on the
side and doing cocaine you know not
cocaine but probably selling
strawberries
and you're like damn i'm not going over
there again bro i'm gonna be full of
fruit and [ __ ]
you know so i ain't doing it and so but
your thoughts keep going along those
same roads
well part of this therapy is supposed to
make new bridges and your brain synapses
so so it's interesting to see this
bridge because that's not what i feel
like maybe i'm hopeful for
i'm up with some of my thoughts say you
know what i'm gonna try something new
this time
i'm gonna try a new pattern because i
would love to be
off of antidepressants you know it's
crazy to me that every day i have to
take a pill
i have to take a pill every day it's
been 20 years now
i have to take a pill um what if you
broke your arm
you know i've said this before and if
you sh if you broke your arm if you if
your arm didn't
you know if your arm said oh [ __ ] it
let's do another elbow
you wouldn't wear a cast for 20 years
so the fact that 20 years ago i was
feeling really bummed out about a
relationship or something
and i went to a therapist and i'm still
on the medicine they gave me
that shit's trying man i should
and it's hard to get off man i'll quit
i'll take i won't take it for two or
three days and i get scared
you know i'd love to be free of that
though and i'm sure a lot of people
would
knowing that every day i have this one
little thing i can't just go out the
door
i gotta go to whatever drawer wherever
my little medication is and do my little
deal
and deal up
and in college i'll be honest i used to
snore them bro i cracked them [ __ ] up
and snored them dawg
i'd be rolling around you know i wasn't
even high but
i was doing lines of something maybe i
was doing lines of feeling better fam
you know what i'm saying praise god dawg
and i'm going to let you know right now
that you can also
try out super specio
if you want kratom or you want kratom
and it's kratom it says it on the sheet
crate tom
uh brendan and chen use it you know i
work with a man named brendan and a man
named chin and
chin was named after a bone a face bone
and that's
i mean that's wild as hell i think you
know imagine having a buddy named uh
occipital occipital jackson actually
went to our middle school but um
superspeciosa
has only one ingredient that's pure
kratom leaf
now i know some people say kratom can be
addictive it cannot i don't know about
that
you know i would check and see if it's
for you you have to make decisions for
you
i'm not trying to tell you it's great i
don't know if it's great
but i know that it's available and a no
creator may be able to help you
it may be able to help you ask your boss
for a raise or run that extra mile
people use it as a pre-workout and some
people even use it as a sex upper
100 satisfaction or your money back
guaranteed
it helps boost energy relieves stress
enhance mood and relieves aches and
pains
that's right it's an all-natural herb
related to the coffee plant that has
been used in thailand for centuries
there you go so if you want to try it
try kratom and get 20 off your entire
order
go to getsuperleaf.com
theo use promo code theo for that
vegetable upper
and for 20 off your entire order that's
right
try kratom and get 20 off your entire
order
go to getsuperleaf.com use promo code
theo
for 20 off your entire order that's it
man
um what else oh i'll tell you this man
uh and this will be our last
advertisement today
is there something interfering with your
happiness
and for me there is you know there is a
lot of times
and um and so that's why i'm trying new
things and you can too
better help is one of those things
better help will assess your needs match
you with a licensed therapist
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely online
that's exactly what it is in fact so
many people have been using better help
they're recruiting additional counselors
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses you can schedule weekly video
or phone session ses signs
that's right visit betterhelp.com theo
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelp.com t-h-e-o
and you get 10 off your first month
betterhelp.com
nice nice uh let's take a question here
it came from
came in from this lady right here
beautiful lady this is nicole from
pittsburgh
i have done
that
let's hear more a question for you
um actually first of all it seems like
you've spent a lot of time in pittsburgh
you always have some
some comments that are very um and
that's true baby girl
and that's true girl baby in pittsburgh
i've been over there
and that's where uh you know they had a
lot of rumors about cordell stewart over
there me and randy in the
in the sand trap over there off of
shinley park
and being randy and being nasty mental
men nasty and that's rumors i don't know
anything about that
and what else did i hear you know they
had uh we went over to shinley once
and a couple man out there watering the
bushes out there with their own body
salt
you know and uh we saw some stuff and i
got pink eye over there as well
so praise god let's hear it very
accurate
uh second of all since you've had the
mullet for a long time
it seems like you are pretty on trend
with hair and beauty
um so i was wondering how long do you
think it's gonna last and what do you
think is gonna be the next big thing
when it comes to hair whether it be male
or female
do you think everybody is going to shave
their heads do you think it's going to
be a half and half situation
or do you think everybody's just have
nice long hair
okay well i appreciate the question here
nicole or nice soul
here's what i will will say is that i
will say that i have had this haircut
long before anybody else had it long
before riff raff
long before morgan wallin long before
um countless lesbians
okay uh rihanna everybody i will say
i've had it
long before
um and i think the trend the next thing
is going to be i think a shaved head but
with
a a cap of some sort
that has an electrical field that comes
out of it like a hologram type of field
where you can create whatever hairstyle
you want
and upload it to your head
so you can actually create
something thick or
thin or long or straight and i think
that that's probably
30 years off no i bet we're 15 years off
from that maybe less even
but that's where i see hair going
that's what i see i see hair going there
with an actual skin
like a a layer a thing that you put onto
your head
and you wear you upload your style
so you could go raggedy ann you could go
[ __ ]
you could go uh
you know thug you could go banker
um you could go
you know uh balding one day
i mean you could meet a girl one day and
she's fine as hook and the next day she
needs keeps
so it could be anything else
[Music]
let's take another one that came in here
here we go thank you guys for as always
hitting the hotline 985-664-9503
and thanks for being a part of my life
what up theo this is brandon from
louisville kentucky
what's up brendan out there in
louisville and i brought a man i met off
the street to a party once in louisville
and he uh he robbed the place and
and broke out a window and ran off with
people's purses onward
and i saw you back in 2019 live and
that [ __ ] was lit you killed it brother
but
i wanted to know what you think about a
certain situation going on in the
chili's world
oh so i was bamboozled by the chili's
because there's a company called just
wings
and you order the wings they deliver it
to you but you can pick it up
so i go to pick up these wings at the
location
that it was on there and
it was a chili's so they're running a
little business
out of chili's a side piece side piece
hustle
what do you think about that they should
just tell you
these are this is chili's and you're
ordering wings from chili's
not try to make some other company and
then have the kitchen workers back there
working all the asses off yeah
and that's called the double up they're
putting on you lance what's the name
lance brandon
the thing they're putting on you is the
double up they telling you it's a shake
shack but it's a sherman's
shrimp shrimp shuck
okay they telling you it's a claire's
boutique
but it's a clarence's bagel barn
okay they doubling up on you you know
that's
that's secondary fooding also
the secondary footing where they tell
you it's albert's ribs
but you roll up in this a damn gas
station
you know it's big al's petrol and they
got a couple [ __ ] out there huffing
dorals
and that's the kind of [ __ ] you can you
know they tell you one thing they
selling lemonade and they
get over there and they got a
wheelbarrow like [ __ ] what
and you see somebody put a straw in a
wheelbarrow some guy who's high or
something
some guy who didn't care about his
family
and that's the kind of stuff that has to
stop man and that's suddenly you're on
doordash or you're on post mates or
something you on one of these apps
and you see nine new restaurants in your
town
but all of them working out of a damn
casey's general are dollar general out
the back
and you got a lady over there big
bridgette or whatever
a brigade you know i knew a girl once
she mispronounced her own damn name said
her name was brigitte
[ __ ] you're bridgette okay you're
bridgette
okay brilliant
she's like oh it's brigand that's your
name
hi i'm bree
you just have a jet person that rode
around with all the time just hit her
with those jits
hi i'm brady jett hitter with one hi
my name is brick yeah jitter jitter
jitter
but what i'm telling you is this here
man um
yeah you get a thing you get a you order
something somebody's selling doritos or
some kind of [ __ ]
and it's a damn uh uh sunoco
or it's a damn hobby lobby [ __ ] doritos
in a hobby
so that's where i'm at baby praise god
man
um what else man we got some good calls
that came in so i think just stay aware
is what i'm telling you brendan
stay aware okay and get your life
together it is together
um here we got a call right here that
came in how can i help
yo theo tyler from texas here
tyler from texas from tyler texas i'm
guessing that would be
unique i just had a quick question man
i know the last couple of episodes
you've been talking about your new house
and me being someone who's wanting to
buy one here pretty soon
do you have any tricks or tips or
anything you think i should know before
going through that process
anyways love the show bro bring that
special to texas
the lone star state baby we love you
many stars in that state man you're one
of them tyler and thank you for the call
uh you know i do have a suggestion when
it comes to real estate
you know i find that some on some deals
the agents make too much money i feel
like
and if you're a real estate agent you're
not going to like hearing this
but you know if it only takes you a day
to find the place
and there may you know it's and it's six
percent
three to each agent if you're using an
agent
then one suggestion if you think it's a
hot market
you're not it's going to be easy for you
to find you could offer to the agent hey
i'm only willing to pay two percent
and some agents will say okay that's
okay
and if they say no i only work on three
percent and then you can decide and do
three percent
if you want but if you only do two
percent when you're buying
then that one percent can go back to
your side of the balance sheet
so you can save a little bit of money
right there
you know that's a one way to do it um
and it's a more ethical way to do it
because otherwise you have to say to the
agent hey
you know can we do three percent but you
kick me back one percent and that's
illegal
that's illegality so that's one thing i
think if you're looking for a spot
that two percent offer the agent hey
two percent you know because if you're
going to buy a place it's 300 grand
you know that's six six six that's
six six six six six
eighteen thousand dollars six six six
and they're going to split that each up
nine and nine the agents
so you get that cut so you get in there
and cop that
then you'll get three back on your side
because you're getting one percent back
on your side
so that said i would just like to pay a
two percent agent fee instead of three
percent
and i think sometimes if it's a you'll
find an agent that was willing to do it
you know um and you can do it
respectfully too
it's just hey this is what i can afford
right now uh this is what i'm willing to
do
and that's just my advice suggestion
it's only because you asked man
and i could be wrong also but thank you
tyler for sending that in
you know we get a lot of suggestions on
here for uh for single moms that are
submitted and i want to thank you guys
for submitting those
if there's a woman you know in your
world
without telling her if you can who you
think would be a good nomination
could just use a little bit of help in
some small
gesture to do something fun with our
kiddos
we would like to be a part of that and
on behalf of myself and our patreon
supporters
uh that's what we we try to do sometimes
and we got a submission that came in
right here let's hit this
what's up theo i see boy jason in
annapolis maryland
uh we got mother's day coming up i know
you were raised by a single mom out
there role playing santa i was raised by
a single mom
my mom was a bartender and she's just
the hardest working person i've ever met
strongest strongest man in my life amen
brother
uh so when on a mother's day i just want
to nominate my friend katie
for the single moms she's really great
she has two kids
uh giuliani i think is seven or eight
and colton just turned five yesterday
oh i got a little nephew named colton
man he's a good he's a good kid he's
he has glasses on too omar uh we work
together in a restaurant
she does data entry for a lawn care
service and then
she started her own business uh cleaning
houses during these
coveted times amen um so i thought this
would put a big smile on her face
and just really be great for mother's
day and uh
i thought it would honor my mom too i'm
always trying to do
whatever i can just a ton of my mom too
amen brother and i feel you there man
enough sweetie to say that
uh yeah it's funny the things we do to
honor
you know the little things we do in
other ways in our lives to honor past
experiences that we've had you know
that's really one of the beauties of
human connection
is i could have an experience that
happened 10 years ago
that was maybe that went well or didn't
go well or whatever
but i can solve that energy from that
experience or i can
share that energy from that experience
the next time some similar environment
shows up in my life
i can do it different i can do it new
or i can do it the same if it was great
uh
so i appreciate that man i love your
attitude here
um let's see if we can't give katie a
call man see what's going on with this
beautiful broader here around mother's
hey katie hi hey what's up my name is
theo how are you today
i'm doing good how are you doing i'm
doing all right i guess i could probably
be doing better but that's just who i
am okay you know
how do you usually do you think on a one
to ten
um on average i'd probably say like a
seven i guess
oh dang okay yeah i do pretty good
that's pretty decent i think you live in
where where do you live at
uh glen burnie oh nice where is that and
who is that
glen burnie it's in maryland so i don't
even know you but
one of your friends there's somebody
named jason that we do a thing on our
podcast for single moms and it's just
like a fun thing i was raised by a
single mom and so
he thought that he would uh he would
recommend somebody that he admires who's
a single mom and so he
recommended you oh that was so sweet
yeah that's pretty nice of him what's
jason like him you can be honest
uh jason's funny i don't know if i can
use uh bad words or not on here but
i've used a couple you can use two i
think that's fair
i don't think this one i can use it's
kind of like
it's kind of like a um a joke just
between me and him
oh it is oh he's just c-u-n-t
i'll see you next tuesday they say it
exactly
okay i you know we get along we both
have uh
kind of dirty senses of humor i guess or
just evil little but not really evil
yeah yeah part-time evil i feel you yeah
pte i feel you there um well yeah he
just recommend he just like uh
you know as soon as we do something fun
like um so we just wanted to give you
just a gift to do something with your
kids we just wanted to send you 750
bucks to go do something fun with the
kiddos no way
yeah it's not much but we know it's
something that you could go do something
kind of
nice what god that is so nice
well you're really welcome what do your
kids like to do
uh they like to ride their bikes um play
get into trouble you know typical
typical kids are they decent children he
said one of them is named colton and one
was named julianna
juliana juliana spanish huh she spanish
no my mom's name is julian
oh that's cute are you guys italian oh
yeah
we're italian german irish just a little
bit of everything
oh yeah somebody conceived on a boat
right there that's something really that
was conceived on a vessel i think
yeah one of my great grandmom actually
came over on a boat
so oh there you go that'll do it
um yeah i just thought it was really
sweet that he thought of you you know he
must think pretty highly of you
that is awesome that i can't believe he
did that that's he messaged me and he's
like you need to answer the phone
blah blah blah and i was like i don't
know what's going on like
you never know what to expect with him
he's he's a great guy
oh that's cool awesome that's so amazing
yeah that's sweet yeah i'm glad uh so
what um
what do you usually like to do what
would be something fun to go do with the
kids you think like what's something fun
with the summer coming up that kids like
to do i think
in the summer um maybe like an amusement
park would be fun
like king's dominion or uh six flags is
kind of
six flags is fun
so that would be cool or like a water
park
yeah water park's good too but a lot of
pink eye at the water park i feel like
that's just me
you know maybe i've been at some naughty
water parks you know what i'm saying
dirty water park i might have been to
some seedy ones bro
i might have been to some late night
water parks you know what i'm saying
um but that's really sweet and so do
your kids go to school
uh yes right now um because of kova they
can only go two days a week so we do
homeschooling three days
um i'm fortunate my mom helps me with
their homeschooling while i work
um but yes they're in school my son is
in
pre-k and my daughter's in second grade
oh that's
cute and what's something that you
really like about each one of the kids
just so that if they ever watch us
30 years from now that they'll have
something nice to remember
um my son is hilarious
he's just goofy funny
um but he's also very sweet like he just
wants to cuddle with me all the time
and always tells me he loves me and i'm
his best friend
oh that's sweet yeah he knows how to
play me
oh okay so he's a little bit of a ladies
man he's starting with that main bird in
the house mom
oh and then um my daughter is just
she's very smart and uh helpful
like she helps me with colton
you know she'll pick out his clothes
sometimes she'll
you know wake him up and she's just
anything i ask her to do she will do it
no lip just she's like just a good kid
very good makes her makes her bed
yeah she might be a jordan peterson fan
you have to get her to read this jordan
peterson when she can read better but
um that's awesome man that's really cool
it sounds like you got like a group that
you can handle that's really cool
yeah it's it's been a rough journey but
i mean
we're we're making it and i'm grateful
every day that i have them
yeah well that's awesome to hear yeah
sometimes we all like
a lot of our listeners i do a podcast
that's why i'm sitting in this place i'm
not in like a roof
like a this isn't like juvenile
detention or whatever but
and this looks like a funeral parlor too
as well behind me i do want to apologize
about the curtainage
but um yeah so a lot of our listeners
are raised by single moms so it's just
fun to like still stay a part of that
universe so
um we just want to let you know that
people are thinking of you
and that uh that and that jason's
thinking of you too so
uh we hope you guys go do something fun
and and uh that's it you can just go on
about your day
thank you you better
well we love you and you know i just
wish when i was young sometimes somebody
would have helped my mom out even just
something little you know
because i know it's really it's not hard
but it's just
i don't know sometimes we all want
people to just
know that we all want to know we're
cared about a little bit sometimes you
know
yeah i really appreciate it oh you party
no look i'm crying too so jesus christ
i'm a damn man i'm supposed to be a damn
adult
um but tell your mom we said thanks for
uh thanks for helping out with the
studying that's sweet of her
all right i will thank like you know
yeah
thank you so much that really it means a
lot to me and
i'm going to message jason as soon as i
get off the phone with you
yeah you make sure to call them that
magic word you call them too all right
yeah okay
and uh whenever i come up and i'm close
you got to come out and see a show we'll
get you a sitter that night and give you
a night off and you got to come see a
comedy show bring your mom out
absolutely i'd love to okay deal that's
the deal
all right well have a nice day katie we
appreciate you
all right thank you i really appreciate
you too
okay have fun all right you're doing
good bye bye
thanks man that's sweet
you know she's a sweet lady and uh and
sweet young lady and i better catch this
i bet
man it's just a fun world to imagine you
know
a mom just having fun with her children
and the little daughter helps out
sometimes
and the little guy he's trying his
little best but he's you know he's being
funny and goofy and
you try to get mom to smile when you can
and make her laugh
and you know
uh all that stuff is just all so
valuable to
the the way that stuff resonates in a
child as they get older
you know um it's cool
and thank you uh anyway uh
jason for submitting her and um and
that's fun
that's fun man those are like that's
just fun it's just fun to have a moment
where it's like
this is life you know this is life
and that's beautiful and it makes me
like
it almost goes back to what we're just
saying a few minutes ago about like
we can take moments from in our lives
and make them different now
you know we can have another connect you
know there's
there's two ends to a trail you know and
so you can have this one in but you
could
you can you can kind of take the other
end and attach it how you will
and where you will and how it meets the
world
and some of my trails i'm just going to
down cul-de-sac and baby i'm out here
c-sacking daddy you know
dizzy daddy out here on the c-sac tip
and so those are some of the things i
want to try to get help with in my life
where i'm trying to
you know try different ways to get help
and
just not giving up it's the same reason
why i go run and why i do yoga and why i
do so i don't want to do those things a
lot of times but i
want but part of me really does want to
you know
i want to get i want to try
and challenge myself with the things
that are a little uncomfortable here and
there
but thank you for everybody that
participated thank you for the name
suggestions we'll have the montage at
the end
of all the ones that came in i'm still
thinking about it i'll put up a
post on ig for
the tour dates that are coming that will
start in
i think on the third or fourth they go
on sale
uh and
what else i don't know a name for the
tour so it'll just be theovon live
we'll just put that out there or
something some name
some regular name like tell you know
alan or something
until we get it ready until we get it uh
finessed finessed but
um thank you guys
thank you guys and uh you guys be good
to yourselves
you know you deserve it man we all do
you know on the way out let's hear a
little bit of matthew
casio runs in the family
[Music]
and
foot
[Music]
it's just a matter of time
baby
[Music]
wow powerful man
can't watch the sin from the hands that
made me
can't outrun what runs in the family
[Music]
we're all part of this long stream
aren't we
you know i'm glad to be in this
wet with you uh here's a montage of some
extra suggestions that came in thank you
guys for being a part of my life
gang how about uh the core
21 tour or the corvon 21 tour
single moms tour why don't you call the
poor
maul it over the uh rat out of the cage
tour
despite all your rage you'll be out of
the cage brother if you're touring
you're feeling the corvette comeback
tour take it or leave it
the tennessee tighten up tour a clock
that i'm cut from
i think let's be honest would be a great
name
why why say when the bullet hits the
bone when it could be when the mullet
hits the bone
sure whatever you come up it'll be great
if you ever come out here to the bay
area nap california
i'll be front row of that show can't
wait to see you wish you all the best
love the show
later